Hello Freak bitches.
You reached out to me about,
uh,
people asking questions about psychedelics,
fielding questions about psychedelic.
Where was the,
what was the motivation behind that?
Uh,
I saw a tweet from a young man hit me up and he was,
he simply asked me,
uh,
you know,
how much you should take some shrooms.
And I,
I don't know.
I was just,
I just saw it.
I was like,
oh,
okay.
I gave him a response and I didn't think nothing of it,
but then I saw a lot of people responded and I was like,
oh,
this is cool.
The other people were asking me questions and then now it's like,
Holy Shit,
this could be bad.
It's gonna be really bad.
But then it's like,
you know what the IMU,
Big Brother Shit,
like if they're gonna do drugs and they want to know about it,
at least asked me to come to me,
you know,
I'll give you the real shit.
You know,
you want him to ask.
Somebody asked me.
Um,
and that's Kinda how I looked at it.
And,
uh,
it ended up being this thing.
But then I know that you talk about psychedelics and you have specifically
talked about DMT,
cause I answered the question about Dmt and that's why I was like,
man,
we should talk about this with Joe.
You know,
cause I know that I,
I mean I can't sit down with anybody and talk about the empty,
even some of my friends,
I've told them that I've done it and they've like looked at me in a way where
it's like,
you know,
Whoa,
you did duty.
It's a game changer,
man.
Yeah,
Pete,
a lot.
But that lets me know that there's people that don't understand it and they're
not educated about it.
And so they just kind of hear these stories and uh,
that's all I was like,
man,
it would be dope to if we just sat down and talked about it and educate some
people because I just know it's,
I mean even some people are scared of acid.
It's a scary thing,
you know,
I tell people,
I remember this is a true story.
Um,
I hope so.
But
this is kind of like one of those things where,
you know,
I'm not throwing this kid under the bus,
but you know,
it's just a reality.
Um,
I was,
was at Coachella,
we were backstage or ran in the Wiz Khalifa,
uh,
you know,
I see him,
often,
and he was telling me he was doing shrooms or whatever and experiment mushrooms
and I was like,
Oh man,
you should do acid.
And he was just like,
no.
I was like,
Oh man,
we,
you know,
shootings,
just like the training wheels are fucking psychedelics and shit.
You know,
it's like he's an old man.
I'm not fucking with that though.
You can just tell that it was just maybe,
maybe he might've known somebody who had a bad trip or he heard some bad things,
but like there was like fear and I was just like,
oh,
it's like man,
it's just people.
People are kind of like taken back when you say you do acid sometimes.
And even when I talk about it on Twitter,
people would be like,
Whoa,
chill.
You want some other shit?
And it's like,
man,
like,
I mean,
well that's the one we're going crazy.
Yeah.
But I don't,
you can go crazy drinking too much.
It's so,
I don't really,
you never had a bad trip on acid?
Yeah,
but it wasn't because of me is because I let some other motherfucker come in the
situation that wasn't ready with his shit.
You know,
you know how some people come in and try to act like they do this and don't do
this and you know you have situations like that but I just have a bad trip and
you got dragged along because you gotta you gotta make sure everybody's cool and
you want to,
you know,
help people out.
You don't want to leave.
Nobody abandoned.
Not feel like,
that's the big thing with psychedelics is if you're doing it with people,
no matter if you know them well or not,
you don't want to really leave nobody hanging.
You know?
And you want to,
you want to try to find a common ground.
Cause everybody tripping,
you know?
And it's like,
you know,
everybody,
at the end of the day we just tripping.
And it's scary because somebody gets to be like woman minute.
He was trying to kill me.
No,
it's so
bad.
I've never had no shit like that.
And I'm pretty sure people have dealt with that though.
Um,
and the second thing is,
and this is what the,
this is the real problem I think in higher education,
which makes me,
it makes me crazy every single day is that right now,
higher ed in particular in the social sciences and humanities is on lockdown by
the academic left.
Okay.
And I come out of the left and I'm left wing in a lot of ways.
And in some ways I'm not.
But what I hate is that there's just almost no variety of discourse on college
campuses that pretty much it.
And if there's been studies done,
I mean like 95% of English and history professors voted for Obama.
Right.
I mean that tells you right there that there's not a whole lot of debate going
on.
Why do you think that is?
Why,
why is academia and the left sort of inexorably connected?
Yeah.
Well,
so when a lot of left academics are asked this,
the answer that they give you is we're smarter,
right,
right.
So that we,
it's just in tiff,
you're intelligent and study,
you will come to that position.
Now I said it because right.
Is kinda inexorably connected to religion because Christianity and the right are
pretty much inseparable.
But even point,
even libertarians who are atheists get run out of the house,
you can't get a job as a libertarian.
Wow.
Um,
no,
I mean,
so it's,
it's all historical,
right?
So if you look at the history of higher education,
and a lot of people forget this,
you know,
a higher education in this country is only about two centuries old.
And as a major mass institution,
I mean,
uh,
the right,
right wing conservatives controlled the joint until the 1960s.
Right?
So what was being taught at Harvard and Yale and Princeton and cow and Ucla,
uh,
was things like capitalism is awesome and black people are inferior and women
should be in the home.
I mean,
it was,
the Conservatives had that whole place on lockdown.
Uh,
there was a monoculture on,
on the campuses.
Then what comes along is the 1960s and all those movements,
although social movements,
so the antiwar movement,
the civil rights movement,
feminist movement,
et Cetera,
et cetera.
And what happened was those people,
because their movements either sort of succeeded and they considered were
considered to be done or they couldn't succeed,
they couldn't really create a radical revolution,
the kind that they wanted.
The only place they found that they could go and have a job was colleges as
professors.
So they,
on Moss though that generation,
the new left of the 1960s went into graduate school and they all became
professors and that's,
he's been basically teaching college for the last 50 years.
Um,
so I'm,
I'm of the generation that was trained by them.
And so there,
there's some changes going on,
but basically most,
even most people my age,
I'm in my forties,
but in my generation,
most of us are still sort of influenced by that generation.
So it was this very concerted,
not a conspiracy,
but it was a pretty deliberate attempt in some ways.
It was conscious to take over the university that that was the,
that was the only place we could have this radical discourse and get paid for it
and have a career.
Right.
I never wanted a late night talk show.
It just ended up being,
that was the format that they called it.
Like I just wanted to show and they said it comes on at a law after 11 and I'm
like okay,
come on at eight.
But there's a thing if there's a person who's standing on a stage talking to an
audience about the world and it's a late night talk show and I was always sort
of rebelling against that format and trying to make it just a show that I would
want to watch.
Yeah.
Well I think you did a good job at doing that.
When,
when a show is on a network,
there's always going to be like a bunch of people that are also trying to change
the direction.
I'm it like you got your ideas and then you got your producers ideas,
which ad hopefully to your ideas,
the director's ideas was added and then you've got an executives and hey man,
I'll fucking kick cooks in the kitchen.
Yes,
you absolutely do.
And that coming from the world of standup and also the world zoom,
I like the solo show that got me the thing.
I,
I had friends helping me and I had people help me.
But it was ultimately,
it was my words were the thing that we're coming out of my mouth and my idea,
nobody,
people could say,
what should you,
you should do this.
And I'd be like,
oh,
I'll think about it.
But when you're in that,
in that meat grinder environment,
especially when it became daily,
there's so many people who are sort of yelling things at you and at some point
you just,
for lack of,
you can't,
if you can't top their idea,
you sort of go,
I guess we'll do that.
You know?
Or,
or if somebody goes,
like,
I just told him,
I said this yesterday,
like somebody will be like,
Oh,
you know what?
I was thinking we could do a cold open.
Well,
I don't really want to do a cold open cause that's just not the kind of show I
want.
Well,
I think if we have,
we have a big guest on,
we'll do the cold open.
Well,
I don't really want to do that.
I asked the guests,
he wants to do it.
Okay,
I guess we'll do it.
And then the guest shows up and he goes,
we're doing this called over.
He's like,
I don't want to do it.
And you go,
oh,
but we already bought the whipped cream and then suddenly had this vision of
like,
why are we doing this?
Why we are,
it's just there's this machine of television and this machine that suddenly
you're just as you either.
I felt like I was,
it was like a meat grinder and either I was putting the meat in the grinder or I
was the meat for the grinder.
And in that format,
when it was daily,
a lot of days I was the meat.